good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast
live and in studio
welcome back we are back a month off
we appreciate everyone's patience during
our hiatus but
we are back and bigger and better than
ever we hope you enjoyed our
weekly episodes i enjoyed the weekly
episodes oh my god i enjoyed them so
much they were so fun we had a lot to
talk about in each episode
these past 30 days have been nothing
short of splendid incredible wonderful
amazing some might say peaceful so
peaceful
and this is the longest we had gone
without doing a show in studio so it
feels so crazy to be back no i feel
weird
i feel weird but i feel so excited like
i feel as though like
my mouth can't match up with the
excitement of the words in my head i
feel that as well but it does feel weird
to be back
um yeah i mean we have a regular show
for you guys today of course fast five
stories we're recapping real housewives
of potomac
um so we're back to our regular schedule
but we missed you guys how are you
we did we really really missed you we
missed
being in the studio i mean thco is here
and i think he's excited to get back to
work you know back to
his normal daily grind he's on his
hustle now like ever since we got back
from our trip like you could just tell
his energy's very different in the house
he kind of like the rest of us has the
blues well you know what i'm mounting
blues
i don't have the blues i have a little
case of the blues just because we had
the most amazing time and it's like
even though like being home is cool and
great in the city is coming alive
everyone
it is and we have to talk about that and
i want to talk about that um
even though all of those things are
happening like what do you do when you
just had such a great time and then
that time has to come to an end well so
like we actually had
the honor of having the longest vacation
ever so like
i actually had a like time to come to
peace with it and when i got home i was
dreading going home but when i got home
i was like oh my god thank god i love my
apartment still the air conditioning is
fabulous like
i i was happy with my home and i think a
happy home life is
is important yeah it is important so
that's why i'm just feeling
i agree there's there's life in the city
it's teeming with life people there was
traffic today i was like yes queen like
it's it's busy it's busy phillips it's
busy
and i guess a lot of people had left the
city for the summer for the quarantine
and now people are coming back and
when you just like drive around the city
like there is a life and it's very
exciting
and it makes me want to like be positive
that things are going to get better
i had made a decision yesterday to be
positive i made a decision like i think
a week ago to be positive and i was
talking to my friend rebecca
and she was like saying but the city and
i was like let's just try and be
positive yeah i just i do find it
interesting that you said like a week
ago that you were going to be positive
and
i was with you for the week and i didn't
really notice a difference well because
we weren't in the city so i wasn't
talking about city things oh so you
decided you were gonna be positive
starting sunday
like when i got back to the city i was
gonna have a positive attitude about the
city until i had it like you know a
reason not to
until proven otherwise yes like i just
i'm gonna try and be positive
and i'm gonna be positive me too and you
know it's like i think when we were
hating on the city so much it was also
at the height
of the summer season temperature wise
which is always even not in the middle
of a pandemic it's always the worst time
in the city because it's just so hot and
dirty
and now that we've come down to a cool
72 degrees fahrenheit
i'm feeling like the city um is more
tolerable like i want to say
there was a lot going on for sure and
the city was not at its best but i blame
a lot of it on the temperature
yeah i mean there was a lot of different
things happening some things that have
gotten better some things that haven't
changed at all
but i'm just going to push the facts
aside and be positive
be positive yes i want to be like
everyone else yeah you're excited to
come back
okay yeah sure and like outdoor dining
let's hit it
i don't know about that no we have to
that's what's that's how you be positive
you outdoor dine
okay but like what about the roaches i
think that since people are coming back
like the roach on roach crime
has sort of dispersed and disbanded i
think they've been like pushed back into
their tunnels like the roach
mafia has been broken up and now like
they're just going and you know back to
their dumpsters and stuff and like
things because the normal cycle of
things restaurants are open people are
eating in their apartments like
the roaches have dispersed because at
one time they were getting super
concentrated in the five restaurants
that were open
yeah i feel as though the big families
the roach families have decided to just
part ways yeah they they've broken up
the monopoly yeah
roaches you you hate to see it you know
yeah
five powerful new york families
no you do hate to see it but it's what's
best for the city
so in order for us to maintain our
positive attitude like that has to
happen
yeah but just as for the corleone family
justice for the roachellos um so we're
not going to talk about roaches today
the entire time i know that may sound
incredibly shocking to you we have a
fabulous fabulous show full of fabulous
fabulous things because we are a couple
fabulous fabulous girls we are a couple
of fabulous fabulous girls i actually in
picking the stories like they're all
10 out of 10 stories can't wait to talk
about them
before we you know dive in and talk
about anything else let's check in with
us
you know because okay we've had a lot
going on mental health check inner peace
check
mhc mental health check my mental health
is strong
my mental health is at its best that
it's been like
in months and i think it has a lot to do
with this um drug i've been taking it's
called kaler
and basically uh
we had the honor of the privilege of
spending the last five weeks with our
niece
michaela and it was just so
it was intoxicating oh my god i was
literally gonna say the word
intoxication i couldn't
figure out the right word but i landed
on it intoxicating just to be in her
presence and smell her juicy neck rolls
like
to smell that scalp to take a whiff of
the kaler
and of course like queen of nicknames
over here like we have
murdered michaela's name and now she's
kayla kaylicious
scalar taylor spelled k-a-y-l-e-r taylor
swift basically
that's where we're at now we'll keep you
updated on all the nicknames but i just
want to let you know like if you
are having some struggles like finding
your inner peace or just like getting
your mental health in check
i suggest you go sniff a baby's scalp
because that [ __ ] is just like i said
intoxicated intoxicating go find the
nearest baby
take a whiff ask for permission from the
mother of course of course
and just let those baby sense
roll through you it's like endorphins no
it is it's it's a beautiful thing the
keeler was so sensational like right
that was really such a highlight of the
trip there are so many highlights and
you know what's so crazy is like we're
the
closest family of all time and i never
thought i would say these words like
somehow in the last 30 days like we
became
closer agreed like we are so close right
now like even we got back on
saturday and then yesterday we all went
over to olivia's to watch football like
we just can't get enough of each other
no i know like
what's it like to have family that you
hate can't really can't [ __ ] relate
um so yeah that's just like a little a
little bit about us yeah so
we took the time and i think it just
like
the rewards came in jokes we really
appreciate you guys giving us the grace
in the space like i know a lot of people
rely on the show every day to get ready
for work or commute to work
and it wasn't ideal not having us here
um but
if you kept up with our weekly episodes
and our patreon it was basically like we
were there every day
there was so much fun to be had you guys
they were so much fun to be had but
again thank you for giving us the space
but we're back
um when we said this on the video i mean
on the audio weekly episodes but maybe
not everyone listened
um there was a lot of conversation about
like jackie and claudia are they ever
coming back and like i literally got so
many messages of people being like
please like don't quit the toast and
then when we posted our keeping up with
the kardashians statement that they were
um
ending keeping up with the kardashians
like so many people just assumed that
the statement was from us ending our
show which
like love that we think people think
we're like the kardashians but whatever
i digress um we just have to say like
plain and simple like we ain't going
anywhere
yeah we said it then and just in case
like you're more of a visual person
um and you didn't hear it like we're not
going anywhere we absolutely love the
show we love you guys we love
doing this fabulous job and like we will
be doing this
until we can't know him out yeah and
like it's our job so we have to do it
you know
we also like need jobs yeah so so
security you know what i'm saying
yes um so that's i think all
we have to catch up on i think that's
like all she wrote for this chapter
i think she's going to launch into a new
chapter and speaking of chapters you
guys it's a great time to become a
redhead like september for me just is
reminiscent of back to school
if you're not going back to school or
you've graduated a long time ago like
the redheads is classes in session is
the book that you read me a redhead's
book
no and i'm actually really wishing that
i'd chosen it because i read her eliza
starts a rumor
and it was so good i absolutely loved it
she loved it and what's so funny about
it is that
at its core it's about um a facebook
group yeah facebook group drama
hello did we write the book it was so
good and so it would have been fun to
talk about on the redheads i will talk
about it and i told like
the crew to read it to maybe someone
else while i've read it and we'll talk
about it during the episode
but no the book for the redheads is the
unraveling of cassidy holmes and if
you're like a pop culture
girl band 2000's era celebrity stan
i think it's the book for you oh wow so
it's the book for ben
yes yeah pretty much um okay well join
the redheads and catch up on all of our
tnn shows
you can follow toasta news network on
instagram lauren elizabeth margaret
joseph they have a ton of new episodes
and the snatchler returns in october
wow that is so exciting very exciting
for claire slash tasha's season i don't
know
what the hell's happening over there but
we'll find out um without further ado
you think
it's time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
thank you jackie and before we go any
deeper you know
get ourselves into a mess we can't get
out of i think it's really important
that we
all always remember something very
important
today's episode is brought to you by
stamps as we slowly adjust to a new
normal we still need to be smart about
how we do business
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier thousands of small
business owners have discovered the
benefits of stamps.com in recent months
you can print postage on demand and
avoid going to the post office
with stamps.com you'll save money with
discounted rates you can't even get at
the post office
and they also offer ups services with
discounts up to 62 percent
and no residential surcharges stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need right to your computer
in the comfort of your own home or
office
so whether you're a small business
sending invoices an online seller
shipping out products
or just a regular gal working from home
and needs to mail stuff stamps.com can
handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official u.s postage 24 7
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send
once your mail is ready just leave it
for your mail carrier and like we said
with stamps.com you get great discounts
like five cents off every stamp and up
to 62 percent off ups and usps shipping
rates
right now our listeners can get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in toast
that's stamps.com enter the code toast
at the top of the homepage
thank you stamps.com we were actually
using stamps.com quite a bit while we
were away because we were in the middle
of
nowhere and we didn't know how to like
ship stuff out and we had business to
take care of
sams.com came through we were on a media
company i don't know
if you guys have ever heard of it we
invented post-its we invented podcasting
okay first story really the big news of
the day
is that tick tock will partner with
oracle in the u.s
after microsoft loses the bid god is
good we're being saved thank you oracle
i've never heard of you before tic tac
and oracle will become business partners
in the u.s
a deal meant to satisfy the trump
administration's national security
concerns about the short form video app
according to a person familiar with the
matter and this is also according to cnn
who's according to a person familiar
with the matter and yes everyone is
reporting that oracle will take over
talks u.s based operations and today is
literally like
the last day of that 45-day time period
to get their [ __ ] together
and yesterday the news came out that
microsoft and tick tock like couldn't
reach an agreement so i was like oh my
god it's over
yeah i was just like what's gonna happen
if no deal
is made like will the app just like
disappear from your phone
right so i'm happy for the talkers and
really for everyone i'm happy for myself
that
this deal has been made maybe i'll be
making
my tick tock return return jackie's been
off tick tock for a while well i've been
putting in so much time
effort resources and energy and uh i
still only have ninety thousand
followers
that's a lot that's a lot like i know
that i know it's not where you wanna be
i i honestly i just said lisa want to be
at a hundred thousand okay so
you'll get there but like i've literally
been at 90 like for months i mean okay
you just need your big break but just
keep putting in the work consistency is
key like
why don't you take some of the social
media advice that you give to others you
know it's like you can't expect to just
become an influencer by the way excuse
me i never
expected that i'm just cutting one day
you will be an influencer
honestly it's never been a worse time to
be an influencer like
honestly i i always used to like
struggle like labeling myself i'm like
what am i i'm a comedian i'm an
influence or a podcast i was like i will
literally never refer to myself as an
influencer even though like i
really am because it is just like i
don't want to be associated like it is
such a bad time to be an influencer like
i am a podcast housing comedian okay
that's what i want to be yeah
okay so then why are you crying about
tic tac toe i just feel like because i'm
consistently putting out like really a
plus hundred content
and it's just like falling flat well i
hear that so i think what you need to do
is sort of like
shift your outlook and so think to
yourself like why are you putting out
this a plus fire content who is it for
is it for you
or is it or is it for these people like
that you're hoping
to garner it's both it's both i feel
like i'm being authentic to myself
while also trying to carve out an
audience for myself and funnily enough
is
i've been saving all my tick tocks and
of course it's like uploading them to
reels where they're just like
outperforming everything like oh wow
slang it on reels but like who [ __ ]
cares about reels i don't know
reels might be the next big thing i
don't know and if it is i'll be left
behind because i've never posted one
that's true and that's something i can
live with but back to this deal we're
being saved thank you oracle
um still unclear like what you do and
like how you have so much money to buy
tick tock but i'm not going to question
where your funds come from i'm just it's
a technology app you know like software
and such
mm-hmm i i'm frequently purchasing
software so i finally
checked you out i'm actually more often
than not
purchasing and such before i'm
purchasing my software yeah so it's
shocking that i've never come across
oracle
maybe you have but maybe they're just
like b2b yeah and i know that it's
pronounced oracle but like i'm literally
incapable of
purple or cool love it love it well
we're so happy that we're all gonna stay
on tick tock
this is an exciting development and
hopefully an exciting end
to an ongoing story this yeah this was
just like a weird story from the
beginning and it was just like the
divergence of like a lot of different
people thank you convergence
of like a lot of different like people
and subjects like people who are
into media we're not talking about
politics people are politics we're like
talking about tick tock
and honestly i'm hoping that we could
just like get past this and
tick tock and just renegade till we die
it's been a while well honestly i just
did like every single move
i know you couldn't see because i was
like going i was watching you in the
screen and i
and you were going really fast
um okay our next story is a little more
tick-tock-related news
because tick-tock star addison ray has
been cast in the she's all that
remake okay this is really an
interesting exciting
a little confusing story and i look
forward to getting your thoughts but
here's
the facts
has been cast in the upcoming remake of
the 1999 teen comedy she's all that one
of the greatest movies ever made we
absolutely love to see
of all time the gender swapped reboot
titled he's all that
like to see that as well has been in the
works for years and recently started to
gain traction again
mark waters the filmmaker behind mean
girls and freaky friday is set to direct
so this is set to be a wonderful movie
on all fronts
the film will reimagine the plot from a
teenage girl's perspective with
easterlink taking on a role inspired by
freddie prinze junior's character
zachary seiler from the original she's
all that i love this movie
um and also i had read that um
oh yeah he's all that puts a 21st
century spin on the original
with the remake following an influencer
who attempts to turn nerdy boy into prom
queen
oh my god wait that's so cute first of
all uh-huh
it could go either way yeah of course
it's probably gonna be garbage but
whatever like now
you could say that but with mark waters
directing i agree but by the way what we
consider a good movie and like what
society considers a good movie is not
the same thing
yeah like i think we'll enjoy this movie
i don't know about society i don't know
what ron tomatoes is gonna give it
i don't i think it has the the potential
to be like the big
teen movie of the year yeah and it's
been a while since
we had one i also feel like a lot of
times when movies
tap into 21st century culture and we're
gonna have an influencer and they're
gonna be like instagramming and like
you're your local high school influencer
it just reminds me of that movie on
netflix
prom queen which i don't think that you
saw
don't waste your time madeline patch
yeah i did see it it was so bad
awful so bad and i just anytime i hear
that there's gonna be like an influencer
plot in a movie i just think of that
movie and so i i shudder
yeah i feel that um but i really am
holding out hope for this because it has
all the makings and by the way addison
ray
is just i mean obviously everyone knows
this she's everything of the sort like
following her on instagram has been one
of the great joys of my summer i
completely agree and when i saw this
news i'm like i hope you speak about it
on the toast because once i read the
story i started formulating my thoughts
and i'm just like
first of all this is a great cast like
for addison's career and for the movie
like
i love the convergence of media and tv
like it's fabulous
but i just think that like addison ray
is a star like i think she is so
fabulous
so funny i love how she's like a good
role model as far as i know
and i just we i stan i really really
stand
yeah let's just hope that she can act
that's really what this movie what will
make her break this movie like if she's
like
a really good actress like this movie
will be really good and like she'll
become
like an a-lister like lindsay lohan yeah
but if she's
a bad actress she doesn't have to be an
amazing actress in order for this to
like really blow up for her she needs to
just be
good like i hope she's putting in the
work since she got the role like with an
acting coach and like taking classes
like
it's important it's not just about like
the tick tock followers like you need to
bring it for the movie too
yes of course otherwise the movie just
becomes like a straight to dvd nightmare
yeah no it becomes like your favorite
genre of movies which is like
bad movies yeah and you know so either
way i'm bound to love it
i'm also just looking forward to like a
full like a screen of
addison ray's face for like 60 minutes
yeah very exciting
it's very exciting i really like the
story development and for the record
like
the statute of limitations on this
reboot like was definitely reached and
appropriate of course of course i'm so
glad you brought that up
um we always say this when we report on
like addison rey's like newest business
venture but yet again i feel as though
whoever is guiding her
and managing her and like just taking
care of like her career is doing an
excellent job whether it's like her
parents or her management
i feel like every time we report on like
a decision or a business move that she's
made like
it's always something like i would agree
with and if it was me i would have done
truth as hell shrewd as hell but like
with long-term
thinking you know like if this does like
be what we think it could be like the
mean girls of our year watch how it's
literally like a piece of [ __ ] straight
to dvd but like whatever
um if it does do that like i feel like
it'll really like change
the course of her career yeah it could i
just love her yeah i like
her dad huge okay next story is really
crazy
um the bachelor's colton underwood
allegedly placed a tracking device on
cassie's car
also claims uh harassing texts so
we found out last week that cassie
randolph filed for a restraining order
against
colton according to legal adopts
obtained by tmz cassie filed
last on friday in la um and
tmz obtained the court docks in which
cassie claims colton's been stalking and
harassing her
with unsettling text messages she claims
colton also went as far as planting a
tracking device taped to the bottom of
the back bumper of her car
to keep track of her whereabouts and
cassie claims colton's been showing up
uninvited to her la apartment
and her parents house in huntington
beach she claims he
takes obsessive walks to her apartment
complex and loitered in the alley
outside her bedroom window at her
parents huntington beach house at 2 am
cassie who says they broke up in
mid-april goes on to claim some of the
harassing text messages included
accusing her of hanging out with her old
ex-boyfriend she alleges colton also
sent anonymous text messages to her and
to himself
pretending to also be a victim of the
anonymous stalker
cassie claims colton later admitted to
sending the messages and planting the
tracking device
okay this is a like a really problematic
story
i just want to say i'm so sorry for
cassie for like having to deal with this
because honestly i can't imagine that
like colton dating colton was like that
great that like you would put up with
some [ __ ] like this like i'm sure it was
mediocre and like
like stay together for the cameras and
now she's dealing with all this
i think colton and i i tried to give him
the benefit of the dab but like yeah
i think he has proved to be like one of
the biggest freaks of all time and like
i don't approve of this at all and he
responded
in like an a paragraph
on reality steve's website it was just
like such a weird this was like major
major news you don't give this to like
gossip blog like you give it to like us
weekly or something you know
um and he didn't really deny anything
but he didn't
he just said like he hasn't seen cassie
in a while like okay she didn't look out
her bedroom window you don't know but
also like
what is that that's like saying like i
ate an apple today like that's neither
here nor there like what answer the
question
yeah did you do it this is obviously so
problematic like the tracking device on
the car
is so insane to me i think the most
insane thing
is sending himself stalker text messages
so as to like not
have anyone think that it was him behind
the stalker no this is like
category 100 insanity level
i'm glad that she's getting a
restraining order this is not how i
expected like this breakup
to go down not at all and
he should really be ashamed of himself
oh i i hope that he's like riddled with
shame
but according to the statement that you
read he's not
i don't know i mean i actually feel
really bad for cassie i feel like
she won the the season in the bachelor
and like a lot of her friends like had
really really positive experiences like
well kaelin got like some [ __ ] but like
calendars now in like a very happy
healthy relationship
and i feel like cassie just like really
couldn't catch a break i think she tried
to make it very clear
that like she wasn't into colton and
like she left and i think in a lot of
ways she got
kind of ambushed into the relationship
and when it was finally time for it to
be over like she just like
can't get away from him and he's like
the like the torturous ex like you just
literally cannot get rid of i wonder
what lucy hale thinks of all this
yeah i mean it's easiest to look back on
all of that yeah and be like of course
he's crazy he jumped the fence at sign
number one red flag
and like she left because she didn't
like him and maybe that is actually the
reality but like it also has been
a year and a half two years since all
that happened and to be in a
fake relationship for that long i think
there had to have been like some
love between them yeah and so yes you
can look back on all of that now and be
like
all the signs were there she never liked
him and he's always been crazy and
obsessive
or like this is she liked him she didn't
know how to sort
out her feelings and i actually wouldn't
have thought at the time that like she
had a bad experience on the match i feel
like she had
the ideal experience like she was just
like the apple of his eye
and she left on her own terms and the
show ended because of her like
and she never had to deal with like you
know an unflattering edit
or some of the things that kailyn had to
deal with and yes got
a happy ending at the end of it but like
what she went through to get there
wasn't even worse most people actually
would not be able to handle that no i
wouldn't have stuck it out to even see
through to the happy ending because like
yes
it's so negative i love kaelyn i love
caitlyn yeah
um i just feel like colton is a freak
and i feel like now i genuinely like i
will never look at him the same again
oh my god never and i hope that there's
like no situation in which like he's on
my tv again like no honestly i'm out
this type of behavior is like so
dangerous and abusive and i really feel
like
bachelor nation would be in arms if like
colton was continued
to be given a platform by abc which
actually i don't think
he is going to or has been he's like has
a bad relationship with abc he like
bashed him in the book
and he's like and i didn't listen but he
did a podcast just like going in on his
relationship with production
and so it's like not a great
relationship yeah but i just think like
it would be a real it'd be setting a
really bad tone
for this show which has a really
majority of like female followers
to continue to give like this is really
toxic abusive behavior like it's
it's like funny because like it's
[ __ ] crazy but at the end of the day
it's like not funny like stalking is not
funny in any way
no not as a freak like in a restraining
order and like
is serious business no it's like it's
like crazy because these are celebrities
but like at the end of the day like this
is these are like two real people and
it's actually really scary
yeah it is um and weird so we'll keep
you posted on on that story if any uh
further news comes out
like justice for cassie justice for
cassie and justice for cassie because
the daily mail posted
uh an article and they used a picture of
michelle that's so crazy to me
but also i hope that like next year
cassie goes on bathroom paradise
or like is the bachelorette or something
you know love to see it she needs
she needs fun love i think bedroom
paradise would be good for her she seems
really
chill yeah and you have to be i mean you
can be crazy and go and sure
but it's good to be a chill person a
great bachelor in paradise they need
that kind of energy
yes are you ready for our next story do
you think i'm ready
i don't think so because i'm not gonna i
don't wanna like alarm you but it looks
like you're having a flare-up [ __ ]
of rdh oh [ __ ] okay let me get let me
get to this really quick
ooh it hurts um today's episode is also
brought to you by
noom getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale
it's about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into a favorite pair of jeans is your
goal then that's great
but there are many reasons why you might
want to practice self-care and every
person is different
because everyone is different neum
adjusts to your lifestyle they teach you
the psychology behind the decisions you
make and then help you to keep track of
everything
from workouts and steps to analyzing
your diet and recommending healthy
recipes
nume also connects you with a personally
assigned goal specialist
and a community of other numerous so you
have all the support you need to empower
change
nume is the habit changing solution that
helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food
through personalized courses based in
psychology noom teaches you why you do
the things you do and empowers you with
the tools you need
to break bad habits and replace them
with better ones noom is not a diet it's
a healthy and easy to stick to way of
life
no food is considered good bad or off
limits on new they teach you moderation
and it can be used in conjunction with
many pre-existing popular diets
if you want noon teaches you how to look
inside your own mind and make better
decisions for yourself
they have one of the biggest and most
accurate food databases available that
lets you track your meal habits
visualize portion sizes and see calorie
density at a glance
we're all strapped for time so noom is
just asking you to commit to 10 minutes
a day
for yourself and if you go off track
there's absolutely no shaming with noom
there's just tips to help you get back
on track
tomorrow chat with your goal specialist
and the new community to get and give
help to people going through the same
thing you don't have to change it all in
one day small steps make big progress
sign up for your trial today at noom.com
that's
n o o m dot com toast
what do you have to lose visit noom.com
toast to start your trial today
that's noom.com toast to start your
trial today
thank you noom everyone check it out
what do you have to lose
okay i said that already no it's my it's
like i just like to repeat like sign on
when you have to lose
okay okay next story kardashians could
ink
a streaming deal with netflix apple or
amazon soon
just because the kardashians have asked
their reality show it doesn't mean
they're leaving tv screens
insiders expect the family to have a big
streaming deal within a year they told
page six
and the source close to the family said
they're even mulling starting their own
media company as we reported
last week the family ditched e after 20
seasons of
keeping up in part because the network
couldn't keep up with their ever
increasing salary demands
now we're told that they're interested
in signing a more lucrative streaming
deal with one of the online giants such
as netflix apple
or amazon i hope it'll go to apple so e
had paid the family 150 million dollars
the last time they renewed their
contract in 2017
but with fellow tv titans such as ryan
murphy and jj
at abrams signing streaming deals worth
of reported 300 million
they could find much bigger paydays
online yeah i mean
now it's come out like through a bunch
of sources that they're not quitting tv
it's just that like you could no longer
afford them especially after saddling up
150 mil like only
three years ago um and then going to the
streaming
wars actually makes a lot of sense
because like they're so expensive and
wherever they go their audience will
follow and they'll have an audience no
matter like it doesn't really matter
like i can tell you that wherever they
take their show like if i'm not already
a subscriber i will become 100
but and there's not that many people or
shows that
i can say that about 100 where it's like
oh if you want to go to apple plus like
okay have fun i'll see you on instagram
no it's really like an institution like
a lot of people were like all right i'm
gonna sign up for hbo max because
friends and the officer on it
it's one of those like cult like um
shows but i do think it's really
interesting this concept that's like
being floated around of them
perhaps starting their own media company
streaming service and if you think about
it like
they're all so different in so many ways
and like kind of how they like flip it
like disick like
he was really trying and not they
weren't doing a good job but they were
trying to capitalize on like each of the
sisters individual like things and how
they did all those spin-offs and
i don't think they really um like stuck
with it enough but i think like the idea
of them having their own platform and
having to fill this platform up with
different content
and you could do like an interior design
with courtney like everyone really does
have their own thing and i think it
would be interesting i don't know if it
would be
as successful and it reminds me of when
they did those apps that i thought were
like so successful but then they shut
them down
yeah i guess i think it was just like
too much work for not enough payoff and
i think when they first launched they
were successful
because that was like where things were
going was at
the time and then that's not where
things are going anymore
so i agree it would be interesting for
them to do their own
media brand and i definitely think they
could they have so much content already
even though he might own it so they
might have to start
but i do think each girl like could have
their her own show but then again that
is so much work and
to also like run a streaming service
yourself like is
a lot of money and a lot of work and so
it might just be who them and they have
so many other businesses that like are
their passions
that i actually think while they might
entertain
what k media looks like they
will ultimately sign with a big platform
yes i agree i think as a consumer i
would rather just watch them on like
amazon prime
but as someone who just like watches
this stuff i think it would just be like
a fascinating case study like
to see if they did start their own
streaming service like how would that
work
yeah and would it be successful yeah so
i hope that we find out soon i feel like
according to this article within the
year and also their next season is going
to premiere
like their next their season two more
seasons on thursday which i'm so excited
and then they have one more season
that's going to premiere in 2021
and then they're done with e so i feel
like we might not get an answer about
this until 2021. it's definitely
somewhere in their contract
like they can't start another show until
at least no they wouldn't start the show
but i just want the announcement like
i'm just curious who's going to win the
kardashians me too and like for how much
yes i feel like you could set a record
like a streaming record they deserve
500 million dollars i mean as far as i
know the biggest streaming deal
that i've heard of is adam sandler with
netflix
how much somewhere between three and
five hundred million two okay
sorry they deserve a billion dollars no
like when you think about it like
they did collectively there's eight
eight of them yeah and the stars okay
they have to give 50
for taxes and then they have to split it
eight ways ten percent to kris jenner
ten percent to kris jenner and then i'm
sure they also have like other
agencies that get a cut and like lawyers
and then they have to split it eight
wait so i actually i think it should be
two billion
i actually think that's conservative i
would go four yeah
maybe put a price on money five just to
sweeten the deal and like just to
outshine
the other competitors that would be
crazy like i think they are worth five
billion dollars
completely agree and i think as a family
they've generated
way more than five billion dollars in
like revenue from all of their
ventures yes it'll just be really
fascinating to watch like what happens
here
watch what happens live yes i totally
agree
fifth and final story little exciting
news for the girl in her cardigan taylor
swift will perform betty
at the 2020 acm awards you guys this is
so
fabulous taylor swift will perform at
the 2020 acm awards on wednesday marking
her first performance at a country show
in seven years
the grammy winner will perform her
single betty from her eighth studio
album
folklore she tweeted on sunday about to
show up at your party
at acm awards if i showed up at your
party would you have
would you want me would you kiss me on
the porch
in front of all your stupid friends i
mean okay so
for us taylor swift fans this is such an
exciting announcement one because taylor
swift is coming to our tv
we love when she performs at an award
show but for me this
goes way deeper and yes i am wearing my
cardigan today no i did not get it for
free like
some other influencers from the website
i pay 49
for it it's okay um but why this is so
exciting is because
why is this announcement more exciting
than other announcements what i have
been waiting for as a taylor swift stan
probably since red
came out red was like her official i
think first pop album even though she
had been like moving in the pop
direction
well 1989 was the first official like
not randomized no red was like still
somehow i've just been waiting for like
her to pick her guitar back up and like
her harmonica and just like be
country and i felt like with folklore
like this is the first time
since 1989 that i have gotten like a
glimpse into of a glimmer of hope that
like we might be heading back towards
country
because when i first started playing
betty and like there was a harmonica
like i just knew and a banjo
i knew that like we were headed that way
like we were getting on a flight to
nashville
and now just having her announce that
she's performing at the acm awards like
that just makes everything i felt before
like much more concrete
yeah and i really feel like the
possibility
of getting a taylor swift country album
like is not is now not so crazy
oh i i actually think that her having
betty on this album and the whole album
in general is like
the closest we're gonna get to country
for a while i don't think this is taking
us like
on a flight to nashville like i think
she stopped over at nashville no no no
he's going to continue on her way i
don't know
i'm just saying but okay these are
opinions so there's no right or wrong
that's my opinion no i just think like
while it might not be the next album or
even the next next album
it's now in the realm of possibility
where i felt as though for a while like
it was
never gonna happen i guess i mean it
could be like the next next next
whatever but i just don't think that's
part of like her plan like i think her
next album will not be country we'll
just say and i think this is her like
appeasing that little girl from
instagram well um
who does a morning show called the
morning totes it's not enough really i
mean folklore is amazing but not to
satisfy my country
needs it really is like folksy it's like
alternative
and betty and there are a few songs that
are like a little bit more country but
it's not a country album but no
no no no but like that it just scratched
a little
yeah no no i feel as though like a
little scratch on my bed hole but like
not enough like a one finger but not
like an x
on the bug bite you know yeah
that's a full scratch yeah um also
folklore is like number one again for
like the fourth or fifth week
i saw on pop crates you absolutely too i
get all my music news from popcrave
um you just love to see it you know you
do love to see it and it's such a good
album and i feel like
it must be so funny for her because she
wrote this out like really stream of
consciousness and put something out and
it's a sign of the times and quarantine
and i'm sure while she hoped that it
would do great things like
there wasn't the whole marketing press
machine that she usually does and like i
i think at this point it's outperformed
like her last two albums uh-huh
and for it to sort of have been an
afterthought compared to like what goes
into love
and what we're adding to the reputation
like wiping her instagram clean all that
branding
and she must just be laughing all the
way to the bank no truly
i would love to be like with her
yeah just like comforting her being like
you did a taylor i'm so proud of you
yeah and i do think that like
industry-wise like this will get
the accolades that she's been looking at
yes i do think uh a grammy nomination
could be in her
in her future i i agree um okay let's
dive into tv recap
dive right in we only have to recap um
potomac but i want to talk about our
schedule because like there's a lot of
shows coming up so we're gonna start
recapping
kardashians this week i'm so excited
dancing with the stars premieres tonight
are we gonna recap i know you like don't
[ __ ] with it
okay i don't watch it but you know like
i think that you should watch it and
talk about it
and also like i watch some [ __ ] too that
you don't watch like love island i've
been watching
i'm on episode six because i have them
all recorded and i know a lot of people
are watching right now it's so crazy i
think more people are watching it
because like there's less on tv now and
quarantine
i watch season one but i don't think it
like hit that big and
it's such a strange show you know what's
so funny is like i've been seeing it
everywhere and people just like love it
but you know what i've learned that like
people have terrible tastes yeah here's
the thing about season two and even
season one like
it's not good but i felt like with
season one like the first five episodes
were like
really boring i don't even know why i
continued watching but then eventually
like i kind of endeared myself to some
of the
people on the show and i enjoyed it like
there was something there that i i
watched the entire season
and i still like follow some of the
contestants and like there was just
something
likable and this season like i'm on
episode six
and i'm just not there and maybe i'll
get there
but it's really not good and like the
way that the show is it's like your
least favorite kind of show it's like so
american idol like
and the results after the commercials
yeah and then we come back after the
commercial and they play like the last
minute of what they played right before
the commercial
and it's like if you took all of that
junk out the show could be 30 minutes
that's like what the bachelor is and
that's my least favorite type of reality
show
don't respect your time yeah it's really
really annoying thank god i can fast
forward but if i was watching live like
i don't think that i would be
and there are some like redeeming
qualities like there's some interesting
folks on it and they play the most
amazing music like that's good the
rights to literally every song
and they play probably 10 songs in an
episode and it's like it gives you
feelings
that you don't feel towards these people
speaking of i started watching rupaul
vegas review which also has the most
incredible soundtrack and i just want to
say it's such a good spin-off they're
basically um
like taking six queens from different
seasons who have just been like fan
favorites
um and putting together a vegas
residency which like they should have
had
that's amazing long ago and the show is
so good like i absolutely cannot stand
nebraska [ __ ]
it's so good i'm only on episode two but
tbg made me watch it
and it's sensational like if you like
drag race and you like all stars like
this is
it's so good and also i need to go to
vegas now and see the the
residency it starts back up in january
it's at the flamingo hotel
also what's so funny and actually what i
do like about love island i'll say is
one they're filming in vegas so they're
not actually on an island this year
i'm sure because of like covet and
whatnot and it's clear that like
all the contestants quarantined and
every safety precaution is being
followed
and they mentioned it on the first
episode like everyone's been tested and
we're fine and then like you're
literally like watching a post-covered
world and it's
honestly so nice but because what's also
crazy about love island is like they
film the episodes during the day and
they air at night and then america votes
so it's like really live it's in real
time it's crazy how they turn it around
yeah
which is really cool um and so just to
like watch these people like hugging and
kissing and holding hands and like
just living a life yeah and they're in
vegas i mean they're
sequestered to dress and the cromwell um
and they just like have rented out the
whole rooftop at trays which is also
cool and they made it look like the love
island villa
it really it's refreshing to see and i
think that's why i'm enjoying it so much
because it's like new fresh content
that's not like
masks six feet apart like
because they all are quarantined now
together yeah
so you'll be recommending that we're
also going to obviously recap beverly
hills in new york this week because we
we didn't get to recap last week but
we'll just do it all together this week
um and there's just like tv starting up
again i guess it's exciting
it is exciting so you should watch
dancing with the stars and share with
the class excuse me
bless you i'm also curious to see how
they do that given
like coveted like are they all
quarantining together and dancing
together yeah i don't know because i've
been following caitlyn bristow
um and she's home well no she's not they
give you like apartments
oh oh but it just looks like when i was
i remember i was following really
closely like lauren elena's
journey last season and it looks the
same as except like when she was in the
ballroom she was wearing a mask
i don't know if they're doing like a
bubble but i it doesn't seem
yeah like a bubble yeah cool mini bubble
love a bubble
um okay let's dive into potomac which
was a actually very fabulous episode
which is brought to you by legacy box
and please pay attention because i get a
million dms about this company being
like what was that company name again
because when you need it you can't
remember it so remember legacy box
an ingenious mail-in service to have all
those irreplace irreplaceable moments
trapped on videotapes
camcorder tapes film reels and pictures
converted to dvd
or digital home movies can transport us
back to unforgettable times when was the
last time you watched doors
we used to watch them all the time until
we finally got them converted this was
before we knew about legacy box and it
was
such a drama like we'd buy all this
equipment from best buy and if legacy
box was around
we would have been in such better hands
legacy box is a way for you to easily
and affordably digitally preserve your
past
the process from start to finish is so
easy you pack and send your items their
team digitizes everything by hand
and then you enjoy and you get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive dvd
or the or the cloud ready to watch share
and enjoy
they've thought of everything they even
provide state-of-the-art tracking and
they send you updates
every step of the process send your
previous recorded moments to a company
that you can trust
and it's such an easy process to keep
you updated the entire time
and it's first of all just like a really
good thing to have because we've evolved
so much since like our time and like vhs
and like those little tapes makes no
sense
um but also it's such a nice gift for
someone who like cares about that kind
of stuff which like most people
most people do like your parents your
grandparents it's a really really nice
gift
um and i honestly just think it's like a
genius
concept for a company because it's like
they solved a huge problem like at least
i don't know if it was just us who like
every weekend tried to watch their home
videos and like
failed completely every time yeah so if
you want to get started preserving your
past today
go to legacybox.com toast to get an
incredible 40
off your first order buy today and take
advantage of this exclusive offer
send it in when you're ready but you
have to go to legacy box dot com
toast to save the 40 while supplies last
again that's legacybox.comtoast
thank you legacy box you guys check it
out great gift for someone you love or
just for yourself
love it okay real houses of potomac was
a journey i feel like
we have been saying like the last three
episodes have really been
i feel like we have been hoodwinked
where it's like the preview is literally
the last 30 seconds
also the last three episodes we've been
saying this episode was okay but next
week looks so good so i did feel like i
got i got a good amount of stuff in this
episode
i think there were two major things that
happened one was the conversation
between ashley giselle
and candace where they kind of forked
over the information
yes and i need to correct myself because
last week i just assumed that they were
going to tell her at dinner
in front of everyone and i was just like
that's so messy and that's not cool
and i thought that that's not what
happened in reality and i thought that
the way that they went about it
was perfectly correct and like minimize
the drama
but like protected ashley's feelings yet
it was still interesting and so i really
respect the way that they handled it and
i take back what i said because i was
wrong in my prediction i completely
agree i give a lot of the credit for how
it was handled to giselle like she was
really like a very calm cool collected
moderator
i had a lot of respect for ashley and
how she responded i feel like on
housewives like i
i this is a similar situation to like
luanne and bethany and tom like when
she's got the picture of him making out
with someone at the regency yeah
um and it's like luanne um
just like blew up and i feel like a lot
of times when like someone tells
their friend that like they have
information about their husband they
like become resentful
and just don't listen to facts and i i
was really really impressed with
ashley's response
it was very calm but like concerned and
she was gonna look into it
and i loved how candace was like you
don't owe us like a follow-up on
anything
i just had a lot of respect for everyone
in this situation agreed and then i have
the
more respect for and i don't even know
if she needed to do this but the next
day when they were like you guys were
all talking and like being clicky and
ashley
actually decided to share with the group
what they shared with her and like she
didn't need to do that because now it's
a group conversation but it's like
she just was being real and i had so
much respect for her again
agreed 100 now where my respect
kind of stopped was really upsettingly
at monique
and i love monique but she was so wrong
like this episode
which part do you think she was like
just super angry at the girls for like
being clicky i guess
and she thought they were being
inconsiderate in her own house but like
what's what she's failing to
recognize is like the fact that they're
on a tv show and like these
conversations these scenes like need to
be filmed like regardless of
if you're at someone's leg house and
they weren't leaving anyone out and even
when she found out what it was about
like
she should have just let go but she
didn't
yeah i mean she definitely overreacted
but i will say like i can
understand that feeling of like they're
not just on a group trip that like
monique planned like they're literally
in her home she made this like
huge fire and like they're in there for
an hour like
being what she perceives as clicky she
has no idea that like it's this major
bomb next even when she found out even
when she found out well then
she had a whole different approach which
was like you guys shouldn't have had
that discussion because
we shouldn't even be talking about each
other's marriages well that's fair you
know what i could and she's obviously
speaking like about her own experience
on both points it's like that's not what
most people would have said or done but
like
i don't disagree with her completely
it's not how i would have handled it but
i also could understand like making this
huge weekend it's our last night
we're all outside and like these are
three key players in the group
and where is everyone like i would be i
would be annoyed too but like obviously
it doesn't come off looking good for her
no i do feel like she just had a rough
weekend like first of all
the group was just being difficult and
like complaining about her beautiful
lake house like the bags like
they were just being annoying and like
she like had to like babysit them
a lot of ways to be like so high energy
to like keep the group momentum up and
you know what like
that's an exhausting place well it's
also your birthday yeah
and then like her husband and like i
love chris like more than anything i
could watch a
whole show about chris but he's not like
they're obviously like having issues and
like
she just wants him to be like more
involved and like excited like that's
just not him so she was obviously just
like having a rough weekend
which when it should have been like a
fun birthday weekend and i didn't agree
with
really anything she said this episode um
but i still love her
and i i respect the fact that she had a
probably a hard weekend yes i agree and
i do think she's like definitely being
a little tough on candace and
it seems like next week is that week
where they get into the
well that's what it seems like but yeah
i will be to be continued next week
um and i'm even though i will no matter
what happens like monique
i absolutely adore yeah and candace like
is not my cup of tea
i have a question though i'm gonna have
monique's back
please explain why the men drove up like
three hours only to go home after lunch
i thought they were spending the night
i thought that yeah the trip was going
to include them i was kind of glad to be
like done with the trip
and everyone was leaving i guess it was
a kind of a cute idea like drive up
we'll have like a group brunch
and you'll go home just like a lot of
work for a lot of work but i do like
when there's a trip
and there's a way for the husbands to be
involved because that never happens
anymore honestly this trip was and
by the way it never happens because
there's so few franchises where everyone
is married or like has a partner
um i actually would have liked this trip
maybe to have been a couple's trip
because it was kind of a boring trip
like up until
this episode and this episode wasn't
even that great yeah i just think it's
weird for like
grown people to like couples i'll stay
in a house together
well the house i agree like if they were
in a hotel it's totally different yeah
but actually
certain franchises like i love the
husbands like i love the husbands in new
jersey
and actually they did that in new jersey
where they all stayed in the house
together
with their husbands and it wasn't weird
yeah that's true but just the thought of
like
couples i don't know it's just something
you do when you're like young but when
you're all like no but also to see your
[ __ ] space
think of the the the setup like wendy
and there was hardly enough room we're
sharing a room so like with their
husbands going to sleep
no that that's beyond weird conceivable
all i'm saying is like i
like new jersey i actually really like
the husbands of potomac and i would have
liked to see them maybe a little bit
more maybe they come the night before
but the whole layout of the trip made no
sense the
they're just they couldn't have come the
night before because the sleeping
there's not enough bedrooms for everyone
to have their own bedroom so like
that's not a possibility but like if
they were at a local
hotel like when they went to nemacolin
the husbands could have
been there yeah but didn't happen didn't
happen
but it was a good episode i'm just i'm
like annoyed with the producers like for
pulling our leg but what is crazy is we
thought the big bombshell of this season
was going to be that text that candice
got and then the bomb was diffused very
quickly
and then it turns out there's like that
picture these other
things that picture justice for gossip
of the city who got that picture and put
her watermark
all over it yeah nuts yeah that's nuts
and i just don't know how ashley is
going to be able to reconcile those
things
but we know that now today she's
pregnant
and so they're doing well yeah well she
said on watch weapons live you know god
has
mysterious ways that is so crazy it's so
crazy
obviously he's gonna like get his
clearly they make their way through this
like how is he going to
make his way out of this which he does
how does he still have a business like
so much so much about this doesn't make
sense to me but like honestly at the end
of the day
i feel like it's pretty clear that like
ashley and michael maybe have some sort
of arrangement
but like he's so [ __ ] messy that like
the arrangement was meant to stay
behind closed doors like him and his
casino and his girl and his receipts
like
he has got to clean up his act because
whatever arrangement is no longer
private
yeah that is very true and it's like
ashley's being understanding with the
arrangement but like don't push it
don't push it in the casino in the hotel
room okay yep
don't push it yeah um all right so stay
tuned for that beverly hills and new
york are coming out this week
and wow beverly hills new york are
coming to an end my week is going to
free up
yeah but then oc premieres yeah
oc is already like the weakest link in
the in the housewives chain
and now they're like doing like
quarantine filming corona like
it looks like they got a good amount of
footage before it though like according
to the previews
i just like i'm over it yeah i'm over it
too
i don't know this could be i feel like
every season it's like why is oc still
on the air
maybe like put those like funds towards
a new franchise they shoot dead horses
like
yeah also salt lake city is premiering
soon oh let's talk about the trailer
i was excited i was titillated
i was dare i say thrilled yeah it looked
very exciting
and i really liked how they're kind of i
think taking this like religious angle
i mean it reminds me of the first season
of dallas where like they took this
charity angle
and they went a little too hard on it
but i just think it's i mean when you
think of real housewives of salt lake
city you're like oh everyone's to be
mormon nobody's going to drink
but i think it's cool to have so many
people in different like stages of
mormonism like ex-mormonism nudiform
jewish converted to mormonism and then
have like just people in other religions
like how they all
mesh and there is this like very
interesting story of one of the cast
members
who inherited this like huge like church
restaurant empire from her grandmother
but in order to inherit it
she had to marry her grandmother's
husband her second husband so not her
grandfather
but her grandmother's second husband
feels so weird still so weird like
they've been married for 20 years and
they have a kid together like and
they're very happily married but you
know what you can't judge like look at
them
the previews in the pudding the proof is
in the pudding that's like when i watch
indian matchmaking like
i know people were very like up in arms
about like how controversial arranged
marriages is even though it's not
arranged marriage it was literally a
matchmaker
like it was not arranged marriage at all
but they had the beginning of every
episode like these
um couples who were indian and who were
set up in arranged marriages like and
like old school arranged marriages like
you don't have a choice i get in the car
and they were so happily married and so
cute and i was like you really just
can't judge
other people or their culture so if you
want to marry your grandmother's second
husband like go for it
yeah it is what it is it is what it is
i'm really excited for that so yeah it
it'll be an interesting fall i guess
like fall is tv season
yeah they're filming dallas i've been
seeing cameron um
and stephanie westcott yeah posting a
lot um cameron scott's also moving out
of her house
where is she going i don't know i really
hope she's upgrading because like i
always thought her house is like a
little small
um for her for her and like even though
it's like so nice i'm not saying it's
still a mansion like i'm saying for my
rental apartment okay like
it's still a mansion and it's still
really nice but it's just like what you
expect from the west scotts of highland
park
um and it just i just felt like she
could do better so
i'm really curious to see where they're
moving but she's been moving it's like a
huge process she's like on her instagram
story it's like going through her closet
it's like making me want to cry
oh my god that's so crazy i'm excited to
see where she moves i know remember her
beaver creek house like that was
everything we need to go there
yeah we do need to go there i like her i
love her so there's just like a lot of
exciting tv and housewives things
happening we will of course keep you
updated on all of that
and i believe if we don't have anything
else to say i believe that is all that
she had written
she wrote it it's done you guys pens
down
pens down time's up thank you guys for
watching we're so glad to be back by the
way we missed you guys so much thank you
for all the support
on instagram and all the positive dm's
we really needed that positive energy it
was a very appreciated very scene
very appreciated very zean we hope you
enjoy the rest of your day we'll of
course see you tomorrow thank you so
much for listening
to the morning toast i forgot
the millennium morning show yeah yeah
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we post videos on our youtube
monday through friday 10 30 a.m eastern
time
on youtube so if you're not subscribed
please subscribe give this video a
thumbs up
our youtube videos are also available as
a podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so it's spotify itching stitcher public
video i have read your cast box
our video podcasts are now also
available on spotify so if you were
listening on spotify you can now also
watch on spotify so don't forget and
please wherever you listen to podcast
find us the morning toast leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
have an amazing day you guys shine
bright like a diamond we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye
you